[Applaus]
[Musik]
eines wissen der zweifelsfrei china ist
wieder da die rückkehr des asiatischen
riesen verändert alles eine neue
supermacht in sämtlichen bereichen
wirtschaftlich politisch und auch
militärisch in der vergangenheit haben
wir auch diese politik stil über china
gesprochen denn es ist ein thema das uns
sehr am herzen liegt und das ist kein
großes geheimnis was wir aber bisher
noch nichts besprochen haben ist was der
westen tun kann um den wachsenden
einfluss chinas und ist damit der
kommunistischen partei in der
internationalen politik zu begegnen
für chinas wirtschaftliche wachstum der
letzten 30 jahre und den anstieg der
geopolitischen und nun auch militärische
macht pekings gibt es keinen
präzedenzfall
noch nie zuvor hat sich ein land in so
kurzer zeit an die spitze von
weltpolitik und weltwirtschaft gesetzt
dieser kuriose aufstieg sieht viele
geostrategische gute wirtschaftliche
konsequenzen auf globaler ebene nach
sich der aufstieg chinas ist auf der
einen seite positiv für die welt wir
sprechen von einem gigantischen neuen
markt einem gewaltigen wohlstand
schaffenden produktivitäts anstieg einem
entscheidenden beitrag zu einer enormen
steigerung der kaufkraft der ganzen welt
bevölkerung nichtsdestotrotz stellt die
art des regimes dass in china die fäden
zieht viele länder vor große
herausforderungen
länder wie die usa großbritannien japan
südkorea australien und auch aufgrund
seiner demographischen größe und
geografische nähe zu china indien
genau aus diesem grund wurden einige
mechanismen ins leben gerufen um die
liberalen demokratien der asiatisch
pazifischen region zu vereinen sich
gegenseitig zu unterstützen und nicht
unter die fuchtel pekings zu geraten
instrumente wie zum beispiel der
quadrate security blog kurz der quad
dies ist eine organisation die ein
regionales gegengewicht zu chinas macht
und einfluss werden könnte wenn sie ihre
volle wirkung entfalten würde heute
scheint sie jedoch weit davon entfernt
zu sagen mutter allianz aus usa japan
indien und australien ist teil von biden
plant china einzudämmen
aber einige experten sind da nicht so
sicher möchtest du herausfinden was es
mit dem quad auf sich hat woraus er
besteht und welche möglichkeiten er
bietet nur schauen sie sich das mal
genauer an
[Musik]
das pazifische asiatische quartett
so wie die nato gegründet wurde um der
sowjetunion in europa entgegen zu wirken
wurde der quad gegründet um 4 1 gegen zu
sagen nun zumindest war das die
anfängliche idee aber die realität ist
später immer etwas komplizierter jackpot
ist eine informelle allianz die 2007 von
vier ländern verbindet wurde den usa in
japan und australien
ein bündnis mit dem auch andere länder
wie singapur südkorea neuseeland und die
dann gelegentlich zusammengearbeitet
haben wir sprechen jedoch über etwas
ganz anderes als die nato die eine
formale strukturierte und
gemeinschaftlich finanzierte und
militärische organisation ist der pott
ist heute schon so was jedoch weit
entfernt
es handle sich eher um so etwas wie den
embryo einer nato für den asiatisch
pazifischen raum der allerdings einige
wachstumsprobleme habt welche nun der
mangel an eigentlich keinen kompromissen
zwischen den partnern und die vielen
wirtschaftlichen interessen die im falle
der schaffung eines nennen wir es anti
china block in spiel kommen würden in
einer region die sich derzeit ob man es
will oder nicht im kielwasser des
asiatischen riesen bewegt mit anderen
worten der aktuelle cot ist eine art
organisiertes forum in denen seines die
mitglieder über politische militärische
und sicherheitspolitische fragen
verhandelt aber warum genau wurde der
quad im jahr 2007 eigentlich erfunden
nur die idee dazu hatte der damalige
japanische premierminister jean so aber
sein ziel war es einen bogen um die
asiatischen demokratien so spannende dh
eine allianz der führenden freien und
demokratischen länder in der
asiatisch-pazifischen region
gleichzeitig positionierte er damit
japan als neue führungsmacht und das
muss gesagt werden nicht nur als rein
passive macht was a b also vorschlägt
war eine allianz die als gegengewicht
zur macht chinas team sollte eine
allianz die länder wie südkorea die
mongolei indien australien und viele
andere einschließen sollte dies kam
jedoch nie zustande
und obwohl die vierergruppe 2007 dann
doch gegründet wurde war dies schon mal
ein verkorkster anfang australien zum
beispiel zog sich im februar 2008 aus
dem quad wieder zurück weil der damalige
premierminister kevin rudd engere
beziehungen zu china wollte um die
bilateralen wirtschaftsbeziehungen
anzukurbeln
außerdem war das land der kängurus und
koalas gar nicht sonderlich erpicht
darauf in ein formelles multilaterales
bedienen ist eingebunden zu werden
da und andere zog es vor seine eigenen
bilateralen abkommen auszuhandeln
dies stand natürlich den krassen
widerspruch zur grundidee des quad mit
dem ergebnis dass er jeglichen sinn
verloren deswegen die der damals in
einem langen dornröschenschlaf aus denen
etwas zehn jahre später im jahr 2017
erwachen sollte
in diesem jahr gelangt ist in so aber
damals noch immer premierminister japans
auf einem asien gipfel in manila
die quad wiederzubeleben er vermittelte
ein abkommen zwischen indien szenarien
der modi australiens melken und den usa
dort trump seitdem mit gibt es den quad
wieder auch mit seinem profil noch nicht
besonders stark ausgeprägt ist es wird
allgemein davon ausgegangen dass der
kurs bei seiner gründung 2007 eigentlich
eine gute idee war aber seinerzeit
irgendwie voraus denn erst jetzt im jahr
2021 kann er sein eigentliches potenzial
entfalten darüber hinaus ist bereits die
rede von einem quad plus oder quad 20
einer erweiterten und erneuerten version
des quad mit mehr teilnehmenden ländern
und mehr strategischen implikationen
eine idee aus der schon sehr bald etwas
konkretes hervorgehen könnte trotz der
unterschiedlichen perspektiven und
meinung ist eines klar der quad der
zukunft wird nicht so sein wie er sich
schon so abe vorgestellt hatte was genau
wir damit meinen aufgepasst
[Musik]
eine nato für asien
schau dir mal die folgenden statements
ab dies ist keine rivalität zwischen den
vereinigten staaten und china
hier geht es um die seele der welt es
geht darum ob dies eine welt sein wird
die auf einem regelbasierten
internationalen ordnungssystem
funktioniert oder eine die von einem
totalitären regime wie in china
dominiert wird mit papier und das ist in
asien wohl bekannteste gesicht der
journalist rationen wurde schnell zu
einem überzeugten befürworter das quad
ein inniger wunsch war dass sich die
gruppe in richtung einer art asiatischer
nato bewegt die immer mehr länder
anziehen würde
aber ist das überhaupt machbar und wäre
dies gut für die region würde es sinn
machen nun wenn man hier etwas tiefer
bohrt stellt sich schnell heraus dass
bei diesen themen die meinungen sehr
stark auseinanderklaffen
[Musik]
auf der einen seite gibt es diejenigen
die der meinung sind dass chinas
expansionismus nicht militärisch
bekämpft werden sollte da diese
angeblich nur wirtschaftlicher natur sei
nicht aber militärischer und ja china
steckt seine zitate in alle welt vor
allem aus indem es mit sehr vielen
ländern handel treibt und dort direkt
investitionen tätigt der größte exponat
diese art von strategie wäre sicherlich
die sogenannte neue seidenstraße über
die wir hier auch die politik schon
öfter gesprochen haben aber bereits in
diesem stadium der chinesischen
expansionen sind die westlichen mächte
und die mit ihnen verbündeten
asiatischen länder extrem verunsichert
denn erstens sehen sie dass sie auch in
stil und wirtschaftlichen bereichen gar
nicht mehr mit china mithalten können
und zweitens ist ihnen auch klar dass
ein rüstungswettlauf nur eine logische
konsequenz der jetzigen entwicklung
einfach die nächste phase der roten
epoche darstellt s-bahn sich ein
militärischer notstand an der früher
oder später zu einer gewaltigen
herausforderung werden wird und über den
wald auf diesen kanal sprechen werden
also vergesst bitte nicht uns abonnieren
genau deshalb wollte trump bzw
marco den quad in ein militärbündnis
verwandeln sich danach gut vielleicht
fällt ihr das nicht auf den ersten blick
auf aber ein solches militärbündnis wäre
eine gewaltige streitmacht sobald sie
sich nur etablieren würde ihre
potentiellen mitglieder zu denen neben
den vier gründungsmitgliedern auch
länder wie südkorea und singapur gehören
könnten verfügung zusammengenommen über
ein vier mal so großes militär wie china
da hatten dabei das alles ist keine
einfache
sache selbst die vier des heutigen
mitglieder sind sich in vielen punkten
alles andere als eigentlich in dem zum
beispiel scheint keine besonders starke
motivation zu spüren in einer solchen
allianz stark eingebunden zu sein
diese art von nato mentalität hat das
sind irgendwie nie gegeben
wenn es die nase schon gegeben hat dann
in anderen ländern und regionen nicht in
meiner dann dürfen wir auch nicht
vergessen dass wir über den asiatisch
pazifischen raum sprechen der region in
der die länder ihr gegenseitiges
misstrauen ganz offen kund tun es ist
zum beispiel schwer vorstellbar dass die
traditionsreichen streithähne japan und
südkorea ihre streitkräfte in einer art
asiatischen nato integrieren und
militärische infrastruktur
geheimdienstinformationen und sogar
durch fast rechte durch ihr territorium
miteinander teilen würden und genau das
gleiche gilt für viele andere länder ist
südostasien
der historische ballast ist enorm und im
gegensatz zu europa ganz und gar nicht
überwunden wir sprechen ja also von
keinem einfachen weg welche ausprägungen
welches maß der zusammenarbeit könnte
der quad also realistischerweise
erreichen nun das im moment wo
vernünftigste wäre eine politische
wirtschaftliche und kommerzielle allianz
denn wenn ich ihn an wirtschaft und
handel als seine haupteinfluss waffen
einsetzt warum dann nicht die gleichen
werkzeuge nutzen um vergeltung zu üben
[Musik]
nun das war mehr oder weniger die idee
des ehemaligen us präsidenten barack
obama mit dem trans pacific partnership
agreement tpp welches eine gigantische
freihandelszone zwischen nicht mit china
verbündeten ländern schaffen sollte zu
seinen mitgliedern gehörten alle
clubmitglieder außer indien sowie ein
paar weitere länder wie vietnam malaysia
und singapur
das problem ist dass jobs sich im januar
2010 aus dem die pp zurückgezogen hat
und dass das abkommen sein ziel
verfehlte ein gegengewicht zu china zu
bilden und die asiatisch pazifische
region als freihandelszone zu einem mit
von den usa gesteuert und überwachten
regel ist aber haben sich die dinge
geändert und das weiße haus hat einen
ganz anderen außenpolitischen ansatz und
genau hier könnte der pott eine echte
gelegenheit für die usa darstellen ihre
präsenz im asiatisch pazifischen raum
wieder zurückzugewinnen und ein club
regionaler demokratien zu schaffen wer
sich unabhängig konstruktives
miteinander kooperieren wo es präsident
joe biden zumindest scheint von dieser
idee begeistert zu sein und will diese
truppe auf jede erdenkliche weise
fördern um die verlorene zeit in der
regierung wieder einzuholen
wie weit das alles aber zum tragen kommt
bleibt abzuwarten allerdings hat der
coach seine arbeit bereits aufgenommen
und zwar sehr zielgerichtet im märz 2021
fand das erste formelle treffen statt
der quad will die impfstoffproduktion
auf eine milliarde dosen für südostasien
steigern um es präsident joe biden und
die premierminister japans indiens und
australiens diskutieren strategien um
chinas wachsenden einfluss in der
indopazifischen region zu begegnen
einschließlich eines angebots pekings
ehrgeiziger im kilometer entgegen zu
treten
dieses treffen diente dazu eine
gemeinsame strategie zu finden und eine
art efx diplomatie parallel zur
chinesischen zu etablieren es wäre die
erste formale und koordinierte
gemeinsame aktion der gruppe
es handelt sich in der tat um einen
meilenstein das erste operative
experiment des quad ein experiment bei
denen auch die aufgaben verteilt werden
um die stärken der einzelnen glieder zu
nutzen
mit indischer herstellung us technologie
japanischer und amerikanischer
finanzierung und australischer logistik
wir haben uns verpflichtet bis zu einer
milliarde dosen zu liefern
die frage ist aber wird diese art von
club der sanften diplomatie ausreichen
um chinas ausbreitung einzudämmen nun
vielleicht nicht allein genommen aber
was wäre wenn
mit gandhis abkommen kombinieren könnte
wir reden hier nicht über etwas weit
hergeholt sondern über etwas das bereits
existiert solche abkommen wurden bereits
in dosen und 40er jahren geschlossen um
der spionagetätigkeit der sowjetunion
entgegen zu sollten und es wäre alles
andere als weit hergeholt wenn hier
anknüpfen würde worüber wir hier reden
nun eine organisation namens das weiß
jedes auge die jede bewegung in diese
regierung der welt verfolgen möchtest du
mehr darüber wissen warum es sich
hierbei handelt nehmen dann höchste gut
zu
[Musik]
die fünf augen die alles sehen wie in
einem science fiction film allerdings
ganz real existiert eine globale ist
geheimnis bilden ist das würde fünf
verbündeten ländern gebildet wird und
dessen aufgabe es ist alle bewegungen
jeder länder zu antizipieren
die ihren interessen feindlich
gegenübersteht und diese geheimdienst
allianz trägt auch noch ein name wie aus
einem agententhriller der vhs sie ist
das älteste geheimdienstminister welt
und besteht aus den usa großbritannien
australien kanada und neuseeland bei
ihrer gründung im jahr 1946 war die idee
eine koalition die ist diesen fünf
ländern durch den austausch
nachrichtendienstliche informationen
ermöglichen sollte die kommunikation des
von der sowjetunion geführten
kommunistischen ostblocks zu
entschlüsseln und so dessen handlungen
vorherzusehen
offensichtlich ist ihre heutige rolle
aber anders als andere der sowjetunion
ostblock existieren ja nicht mehr also
konzentriere sich die fans hauptsächlich
auf russland nordkorea und natürlich
china tatsächlich machte china die
länder derzeit zudem kurzzug gegen way
verantwortlich ähnlich chinesischen
chemiekonzern der 2018 der beschaffung
vertrauliche informationen für die
chinesische regierung und des diebstahls
von militärtechnologie beschuldigt wurde
warum dies so wichtig ist wurde der quad
nicht nur ein diplomatisches politisches
und wirtschaftliches - werden sondern
auch nach dem vorbild der weist die
geheimdienste seiner mitglieder
einbeziehen könnte der schaden für china
in bezug auf einfluss und macht viel
größer werden die mächtigsten länder der
welt könnten ihre vertraulichen
informationen über china miteinander
teil ihre pläne koordinieren und
konzertierte operationen durchführen
dadurch würden sie ihre sicherheit stark
erhöhen und ihre fähigkeit potenziellen
bedrohungen aus peking zuvorzukommen
enorm steigern
im umkehrschluss würde dies die
handlungsfähigkeit der kommunistischen
partei chinas stark untergrabe
sie würde nicht nur die regeln bestimmen
können oder müsste zumindest wesentlich
vorsichtiger vorgehen
und könnte sich nicht mehr alles leisten
das alles klingt nicht nach einer
schlechten licht war nun leider muss ich
dir aber verraten dass japan und indien
es wohl nicht schaffen werden sich mit
dem gleichen engagement in das gar
nichts bündnis zu integrieren wie die
anderen vier mitgliedsländer zu groß
sind die nationale vorbehalte und auch
in politischen eitelkeiten in diesen
ländern schwächen die peking gut kennt
und sicher dazu ausnutzen wird um diese
nationen gegeneinander auszuspielen und
zu schwächen auf jeden fall sieht es
aber so aus dass die usa die genannten
wichtigen schritte gehen werden um ihre
präsenz in der region wieder zu beleben
und ein gegengewicht zu china zu bilden
aber was glaubst du denkst du dass die
nordallianz effektiv sein könnte um die
china im asiatisch pazifischen raum
sowie gegen denkst du dass der sport
eine rein diplomatische und kommerzielle
allianz sein sollte oder eher eine
asiatische nato an schließlich eine
integration der geheimdienste welche
hindernisse fallen dabei ein
falls doch bitte uns und allen anderen
eure meinungen in einem kurzen kommentar
unter diesem video mit und fasst euch
gefallen hat geht uns mit einleitenden
und folgen und vergesst nicht unseren
kanal zu abonnieren was gut und bis bald
[Musik]